[Laughter]
like there are things that annoy her but
you do it all the time
like yeah i always i was trying to annoy
her like would you like fart on her uh
no so like um you fart in front of her
though yeah yeah all the time but she
she gets mad because my fart's really
like they stick really bad all right
i'll beat you every day any day bro you
want to have a fart battle yeah my [ __ ]
dude i might have the part now i don't
know how we would have i can't even push
that right now if i wanted to but you
know what we could do what we could
light them on fire to see what happens
who gets like the largest but doesn't
that
burn the smell
yeah mel's gone okay but there's
different tests
that's potency gas potency okay right so
that's one thing gas potency gas potency
the other one is um
just smell okay we could judge it on
that and how do we do that do we have a
third-party smeller yeah yeah we you
need judges okay and the third thing is
also um
consistency consistency my [ __ ] has like
[ __ ] in it yeah he has debris yeah
so instead of like making the fire
bigger he puts out the fire oh yeah
like mine's an ied
oh okay where there's like shrapnel that
comes out right like [ __ ] shrapnel so
it's like it's like vaporized sharks
yeah yeah so you'd have to beat me on
content too you know what i mean so um i
think you win then why because you're
just all spray yours is all uh what gas
from what people describe to me is that
it is thick and it's humid oh and it
doesn't and it lingers southern okay
that's it that's another lingerie
yeah and even if i fart outdoors the
wind doesn't blow it away whoa so it's
sturdy yes it's sturdy it's a rain cloud
but i've never had vaporized shards
wow i love that turkey
there was never you see you don't what
you what you were telling me is when you
farted nothing came out except for gas
yes it's pretty clean yeah pretty cool
but a thick heavy gas a fake heavy guilt
yeah that smells the potency is good the
smell so yours you fart actual material
yeah
what do you eat
um donuts
skittles skittles for breakfast sour
kids enzymata
yeah i mean i all kinds of things but um
not healthy i see right but is it
because you're you eat well huh no so i
actually fart the most when i eat clean
like when i'm eating like rice broccoli
chicken that's where i fart the most if
i eat mcdonald's i have no farts wow so
that's why but can you for okay how do
we have a contest babe i would just have
to eat something healthy
yeah i think that you guys should
probably spend the day eating the same
thing and that's you have to be equal
and measure right but what if our
triggers are different
oh that's true but he doesn't even know
his his triggers that's the thing i
don't know oh no i do know his triggers
you're lactose intolerant milk milk oh
yeah yeah very good baby yeah very good
so i'll just get some vitamin d whole
milk right
and i'll go to get some donuts yeah and
then we'll
you can eat some a bowl of broccoli yeah
and then
i'm gonna actually do that one day you
guys should totally do this yeah we'll
just see if it if it even works and who
do we nominate as a judge geo and my
girlfriend kalila and your girl and your
wife okay because they're two
girls that are you know
in the internet right so people know who
they are
and then also i mean gio is a little bit
more famous sorry a lot more yeah but
she's she's gonna she's she's on her
wall she's honored hey you listen i want
to promote my girlfriend right yeah
don't [ __ ] sleep on her yeah
all right this is right here legit
and i would not be doing it if it wasn't
so i know you're going how many
followers i would i don't even ask you i
know but i can see you're a little
[ __ ] too cute
yeah and i felt it so um i'm just this
is legit
okay geo is legit come on mike kalala's
legit okay and i like gio she's very
talented
person but don't sleep on my girl i'm
not talking all right
yeah
i just want to throw i think she's a
better host than you are
i don't know why my size got itchy i had
to scratch my sides because um
so we'll have a far competition anyway
so